DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
RECENTLY, CNN ASKED, WITH ALL
THE GOOD NEWS, WHY AREN'T PEOPLE
SMILING?
IT IS LIKE THE LOCAL SKUNK
WONDERING WHY EVERYTHING AROUND
HIM STINKS.
CLUELESS RESULTS FROM THE
COMPLETE DENIAL OF HOW
DONALD TRUMP WORKS, FUELED BY
CONFIRMATION BIAS THAT SEEKS
ONLY TO PROVE THEIR NEGATIVE
POINT.
TAKE NORTH KOREA.
MONTHS AGO, IT WAS A NUCLEAR
WAR.
>> TRUMP'S FURY.
>> HE WILL RESPOND TO
NORTH KOREA WITH A FIRE AND
POWER THE WORLD IS NEVER SEEN.
WILL THEY WERE WORDS ESCALATE
INTO AN ACTUAL NUCLEAR WAR?
>> WHAT HE SAYS IF THERE'S GOING
TO BE MORE THREATS, NOT AN
ATTACK, BUT MORE THREATS FROM
NORTH KOREA, WE ARE GOING TO SEE
IN EFFECT A NUCLEAR WAR.
>> PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TODAY THREATENED
NUCLEAR WAR.
>> Greg: THAT DID NOT AGE
WELL, NOR SHOULD IT.
WE CAN'T LET THE PRESS FORGET
IT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN TRUMP PEGS TO
START MEETING WITH AN
UNPREDICTABLE MAN WITH A STRANGE
HAIRCUT.
ENOUGH ABOUT RODMAN.
ROCKET MAN.
MONTHS AGO, HE WAS DOCTORING
EVIL.
NOW HE IS AT THE TABLE.
REMINDS ME OF A SITCOM FROM THE
'90s.
>> SO WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Greg: OH, GOD.
BEFORE YOU SAY KIM WINS BY
INCLUSION, ISN'T THAT HOW
DIPLOMACY WORKS?
MEET WITH THE GUIDE, TALK TO
HIM.
IT'S FUNNY.
DIALOGUE USED TO BE THE LEFT'S A
BOARD.
WE ARE ALWAYS BEING TOLD WE NEED
A NATIONAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
STUFF, SO HERE'S AN
INTERNATIONAL CONVERSATION.
YET THE SAME WHO CONDEMN TRUMP'S
FIRE AND FURY CHIDE THE
OPPOSITE.
MAYBE IF TRUMP SAYS HE IS
DIALOGUING WITH KIM, CNN CAN
AVOID ANOTHER CRYING JAG.
WE HAVE GONE FROM FRETTING OVER
WHERE TO DEBATING THE HOTEL
BILL.
HOW CAN THE PRESS MISSED THIS?
THEY HATE THE GUY, TRUMP, THAT
IS.
THEY ARE SO MARRIED IS SAFE,
PREDICTABLE POLITICIANS WHOSE
MAIN RISK INVOLVES CHOOSING THE
RED TIE FOR THE FUND-RAISER,
TRUMP RUN CIRCLES AROUND THEM
BECAUSE IN HIS WORLD, HE HAS TO.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE.
KIM MAY BE A DICTATOR BUT TRUMP
IS A DEVELOPER FROM QUEENS.
I AM NOT SURE WHAT IS SCARIER.
ALL RIGHT, I GUESS I SHOULD
BREAK THE NEWS HERE THAT I AM
GOING TO SINGAPORE.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
I DON'T HAVE MY CREDENTIALS YET.
>> Dana: HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
DO ON THE PLANE?
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO DO
GREAT.
GORKA IS GOING.
SO IF GORKA IS GOING, I THINK I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO, RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kimberly: GOD HELP WHOEVER
IS FLYING NEXT TO YOU ON ANY
FLIGHT.
>> Greg: WHY SHOULDN'T ONE OF
US BE ABLE TO GO?
>> Brian: "WATTERS' WORLD"
SHOULD DEFINITELY GO.
>> Greg: YOU WITH DIAMOND AND
SILK.
>> Kimberly: RODMAN.
>> Juan: LORD HAVE MERCY.
THAT INTRO, IT WAS SO RIDICULOUS
THAT INTRO, IT WAS SO RIDICULOU
RIDICULOUS.
IT'S LIKE AN '70 SHOW BUT THE
THING IS, THAT'S THE WORLD WE'RE
LIVING IN.
DENNIS RODMAN.
COME ON, MAN.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
NOW YOU'RE APPROACHING THE POINT
WHERE YOU SAY THIS ISN'T -- THIS
IS ABSURDITY.
IT'S LIKE SOMETHING SOMEONE
DREAMED UP A PLAY AND YOU SAY NO
ONE IS GOING TO BELIEVE THAT.
JUMPED THE SHARK A LONG TIME
AGO.
>> Greg: THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED BEFORE AND
MAYBE THAT'S WHY IT'S HAPPENING.
DANA.
THEY TOOK A SALESMAN FROM QUEENS
THEY TOOK A SALESMAN FROM QUEEN
QUEENS.
THE PROCESS, YOU LOOK AT IT LIKE
A PROCESS.
BUYING A HOUSE OR RENOVATING A
PROPERTY.
COULD YOU SAY THAT'S HOW HE'S
LOOKING AT THIS?
>> Dana: MAY BE.
BUT I ALSO THINK ONE OF THE
REASONS IT'S HAPPENING IS
BECAUSE THE KIM FAMILY,
KIM JONG UN BEING THE ULTIMATE
ONE, THEY GOT THE NUCLEAR WEAPON
ONE, THEY GOT THE NUCLEAR WEAPO
WEAPON.
NOW THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
EQUALS.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE AN
ABILITY TO COME TO THE TABLE AND
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE.
THE STICKING POINT ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION, WHAT IS REALLY
MEAN AND HOW DOES IT ALL WORK.
I WOULD TEND CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC.
NOT NECESSARILY A CYNIC OR
SKEPTIC.
I HOPE IT WORKS.
I ALSO KNOW WE ARE DEALING WITH
THE NORTH KOREANS.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST
DOPES LIKE ME WHO WERE
SKEPTICAL.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY IS.
>> Dana: THE SHOW IS CALLED
"WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS."
>> Juan: GREG IS DEFENDING THE
PRESIDENT IS A SALESMAN FROM
QUEENS.
HE'S JUST A GUY FROM QUEENS.
THE DEMOCRATS' ARGUMENT WOULD BE
WAIT A SECOND.
DON'T WE USUALLY HAVE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MASTERED FOREIGN AFFAIRS
AND DIPLOMACY INVOLVED.
THEY DECIDED, BELIEVE ME, THERE
WERE PREVIOUS OFFERS FROM THE
KIM FAMILY, THE GRANDFATHER,
FATHER, NOW HIM, FOR MEETINGS
BUT EVERYBODY SAID NO BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT GIVING YOU THAT.
YOU SAID THAT WAS DOPEY AND
OLD-SCHOOL.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT TRUMP
IS.
HE IS LIKE "THE BLAIR WITCH
PROJECT."
AFTER THAT MOVIE CAME OUT, ALL
OF THE MOVIES CHANGED.
>> Dana: WITH THE HORRIBLE
CAMERAWORK.
>> Greg: I WAS TERRIFIED.
I WANT TO RESPOND TO JUAN'S
MISGUIDED BELIEF WE SHOULD BE
DOING THE SAME THING.
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SAY THE SAME
THING.
AS DANA SAID, THE MAN HAS NUKES
NOW.
HE DIDN'T HAVE NUKES BEFORE.
>> Greg: HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> Kimberly: HERE IS THE
THING.
PEOPLE GET UPSET, THEY THINK
RODMAN IS LIKE A SIDESHOW.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY NOT GOING TO HAVE
ANY PLACE IN THE NEGOTIATIONS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
KIM JONG UN.
IF KIM JONG UN FEELS MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH HIS FRIEND FOR
LIFE, DENNIS RODMAN THERE, FINE.
GIVE HIM HIS SECURITY BLANKET.
LET HIM HAVE HIM THERE.
IT WILL BE FINE.
WHO CARES?
THAT IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
ULTIMATELY IF THE GOAL GETS
ACHIEVED IN THEIR CALL FOR
SOMETHING AND THEY ARE ABLE TO
DENUCLEARIZE, WOULD ANYBODY
REALLY CARE WHETHER DENNIS
RODMAN WAS IN THE COUNTRY AT THE
TIME OR NOT?
I HAVE ABOUT THE RESULTS AND
MOVING ON TARGET AND GETTING YOU
THE FINISH LINE.
IF THAT IS SOME KIND OF PECULIAR
THING THAT MAKES HIM FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE THAT IT ISN'T SOME
KIND OF ASSASSINATION PLOT ON
HIM OR SOMETHING, AND HE'S LIKE
OKAY, I'M GOING TO BE SAFE.
MY BUDDY.
HE'S BEEN THERE SIX TIMES IN
NORTH KOREA.
>> Brian: YOU REMEMBER WHEN
THEY LEFT SENT JAMES TAYLOR TO
EUROPE, THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS
BRILLIANT.
TRUMP SENDS RODMAN AND HE GETS
BEAT UP FOR THAT.
I DON'T SEE WHAT THE
DIFFERENCES.
KIMBERLY'S POINT IS RIGHT.
HE HAS MET LITTLE ROCKET MAN
MORE THAN ANY OTHER AMERICAN ON
THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
THEY HAVE SOME KARAOKE TOGETHER.
THEY HAVE GONE SKIING TOGETHER.
THEY PLAYED PING-PONG,
BASKETBALL.
LISTEN TO THE THINGS HE SAID
ABOUT DENNIS RODMAN.
HE SAYS HE'S LIKE A LITTLE KID
WHO DOESN'T WANT MORE.
THINGS AMERICANS ARE GOING TO
TRY TO TAKE OVER THE COUNTRY SO
HE WANTS HEATH -- HE FEELS LIKE
THAT'S HIS ONLY DEFENSE.
HE WANTS TO HAVE WITH CULTURE
IMPROVED.
AND HE LOVES AMERICA.
THEY SAID WHEN HE WENT OVER
THERE, HE PLAYED THE SOUNDTRACK
OF "DALLAS."
>> Kimberly: HE IS LIKE GREG.
>> Jesse: FOR FOUR HOURS, HE
PLAYS THOSE THEME SONGS.
>> Greg: SO HE IS INSANE.
>> Jesse: TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
REAL ESTATE, HE IS LIKE A
MOTIVATED BUYER.
HE REALLY WANTS HIS COUNTRIES TO
SUCCEED AND HE REALLY WANTS --
HE WANTS MONEY AND TRUMP POINTS
OUT THIS GUY OUT.
HE BRINGS HIM TO THIS FIVE-STAR
LUXURY RESORT OR ITS LEICA $3500
TASTING MENU, PEACOCKS ROAMING
AROUND.
THIS EAST MEETS WEST DEAL.
$6,000 PRESIDENTIAL SUITE.
HE IS SAYING CAPITALISM CAN BE
GOOD IF YOU DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> Kimberly: AND NOW HE HAS
READ "ART OF THE DEAL."
>> Greg: IT'S AN OLD SALES
TACTIC THAT YOU HAVE THE CLIENT
THINKING THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO
LOSE THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE.
SO THEY HAVE GOTTEN THIS FAR.
I HAVE THIS BEFORE.
GIULIANI WAS TALKING ABOUT
NORTH KOREA AND HE SAYS HE'S GOT
NORTH KOREA ON ITS KNEES.
THESE ARE THE THINGS YOU
SHOULDN'T BE SAYING.
>> Dana: IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
>> Greg: NO, GIULIANI, STOP.
>> Dana: SAY IT AT PRIVATE
DINNER PARTY, NOT TELEVISION.
>> Greg: HE WANTED TO FEEL
LIKE A WHEN-WIN.
>> Juan: THE REAL PERSON WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT GOING IS
JOHN BOLTON.
>> Greg: IS HE GOING?
>> Juan: YES.
I THINK HE IS THE ONE THAT
SCARES KIM JONG UN, RIGHT?
>> Greg: I AGREE.
>> Juan: AS JESSE WAS ALLUDING
TO, SOMEONE CAN TAKE HIM OUT AND
WHAT HAPPENS TOMORROW MARK
QADDAFI WHEN WE MADE THE --
>> Greg: IT WAS THE PROBLEM
WHEN BOLTON SAID THAT.
>> Juan: CONTINGENT ON PART OF
THAT IS I THINK BOLTON WAS A BIG
PROPONENT OF THE IRAN DEAL.
IDEALLY IF WE HAD THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOME FROM WHAT
HAPPENS, YOU KNOW WHAT, IT WOULD
BE THE NORTH KOREAN DEAL ALONG
THE LINES OF THE IRAN DEAL WHEN
BOLTON IS AN OPPONENT THERE.
>> Jesse: YOU MEAN WHEN YOU
CAN SELF INSPECT YOUR OWN
NUCLEAR FACILITIES.
>> Juan: GO ON WITH THAT BOGUS
ARGUMENT.
>> Jesse: YOU WANT TO HAVE A
THING -- $6 BILLION IN CASH.
>> Juan: EVEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CERTIFIED THE
DEAL.
I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE, BY
THE WAY, IS WE GO BACK AND SAY
THE KOREAN WAR IS OVER, WE ARE
GOING TO BE FRIENDS.
THIS IS THE START OF THE
PROCESS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SAID MUCH
THE SAME.
>> Greg: BREAKING NEWS TODAY
ABOUT, IN AP, PRESIDENT OBAMA
FUDGING ABOUT THE IRAN --
>> Jesse: APPARENTLY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION LED THE IRANIANS
TO SKIRT THESE FINANCIAL
SANCTIONS TO GIVE THEM ACCESS TO
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF HARD
AMERICAN CURRENCY.
NO ONE KNEW THAT.
THEY HAD TO GET A LAWSUIT FROM I
BELIEVE JUDICIAL WATCH TO FIND
THAT OUT.
THEN THE AP REPORTED.
TO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE IRANIANS,
LARGEST STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR
TO GET CASH BEHIND THE WORLDS
BACK AND THAT'S NOT A SCANDAL?
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT A SCANDAL.
YOU KNEW THE WHOLE IDEA WAS TO
GIVE THEM THE MONEY WE HAD
FROZEN.
IT WAS THEIR MONEY IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
SECONDLY, TRY TO REINTEGRATE
THEM INTO THE GLOBAL ECONOMIC
STRUCTURE.
>> Jesse: WHY DID THEY HIDE
IT?
>> Juan: JUST YOUR REACTION.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT ME TO REACT LIKE THAT?
>> Juan: THEY DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO GO HYPERBOLIC.
>> Kimberly: DAY NOW.
>> Dana: IT'S NOT ONLY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY
WENT TO A COUPLE AMERICAN BANKS
AND TRIED TO ASK HIM TO DO THIS,
IT'S NOT MONEY-LAUNDERING BUT IT
KIND OF FEELS LIKE THAT WHICH IS
BASICALLY MAKE THIS MONEY RIGHT
IN THE BANKS REFUSED.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SAYING
BANKERS HAVE HIGHER ETHICAL
STANDARDS THAN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
>> Dana: IT WAS ABOUT CONCERN
THEY WOULD BE PENALIZED BECAUSE
OF IT.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY.
LAST WORD.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA IS
GOING TO COVER IT.
>> Kimberly: SENSATIONAL.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO MAKE
SOME JOKES ABOUT IT LIKE DENNIS
RODMAN, LIKE THEY HAVE.
I THINK THE OUTCOME IS GOING TO
SPEAK FOR ITSELF IN TERMS OF
BEING RESULT ORIENTED, HE'S
GOING TO DO WHAT HE DOES IS ABLE
TO WORK A DEAL.
HE'S ABLE TO GO AND MEET WITH
KIM JONG UN WHEN NO ONE ELSE WAS
ABLE TO GET HIM TO THE TABLE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT I FOUND
IN THE GREEN ROOM?
I FOUND THIS BOOK.
IT'S NEWT GINGRICH'S BOOK.
TO STEVE DOOCY, A GREAT GUY WHO
HAS BEEN A FRIEND IN THE
MORNING.
STEVE LEFT IT IN THERE.